what's going on in La now as you know La
has a new mayor her name is Mayor Karen
bass she replaced Eric Garcetti who was
a far left Progressive who was Bowing in
front of BLM activists at the height of
kovid you could go out and protest but
you couldn't go to work literally on his
knees in front of these people anyway
they brought in another far left whack
job mayor Karen bass and listen to how
she's going to be dealing with
homelessness this is from about three
months ago
are you still going to allow LAPD and
sanitation officers to do these sweeps
of encampments
sweeps at all this is getting people to
move on their own but then after the
person leaves sanitation is absolutely
going to have to be there no question
about it but this is not coercing people
this is not ticketing people or
incarcerating people this is moving
people from tents to hotels or motels
you know it's funny guys when I've been
to hotels and I've been to a couple in
my life motels Motel Six I've been to
Best Westerns I've stayed at some nicer
places every now and again I generally
have to pay to be to go to a hotel is
that that yeah for everybody yeah that
uh you see what they're doing first off
she's saying no we're not going to move
these people of course they're moving
these people these 10 cities come up all
over La in many cases they don't move
them and then and then it becomes drug
infested and and it's medically not safe
and infectious and all that stuff right
and it's a blight on the neighborhood
and then houses prices go down all of
that stuff obviously but they will
obviously move these people but then
what do they do this is the same exact
thing that Gavin knew some lizard person
Gavin Newsom was saying he was going to
do in San Francisco about 15 years ago
when he was at the mayor we will take
these people because it's a housing
problem it's not a uh mental health
problem or a drug problem or anything
else it's just a housing problem so we
will take these people and we will put
them in hotels and motels I I really
just why you think like joking aside for
just a second like if you were to
picture just like the average homeless
person of San Francisco and L.A right so
you have to picture someone who is on
drugs who is mentally not well who's
probably screaming and fighting with
people and all we're going to put them
in the Ritz Carlton put them on the
penthouse floor next to Richard Gere and
that chick like it's so that was the
Beverly Wilshire for those of you paying
attention pretty woman
um it's so nuts it's so completely
ridiculous but it seems right this is
what progressives are really good at oh
we will put we care about homeless
people so we will put them in hotels and
motels and then we'll give them a little
card and they can get room service above
does that help anyone get off the drugs
does it help anyone with their mental
health does it actually create a
situation where these people will not
live in those hotels or motels forever
does it get anyone off the city door or
does it just kick the can down the road
so that is the model that California has
chosen
oh
[Music]